what is up there people we're gonna
watch today black widow alternate ending
deleted scene revealed from our homie
cosmic wonder breaking this down for us
don't know what's in it but i really
wanted to cover this because last night
i did have a dream that i was uh airbnb
at a place in the woods obnoxiously big
like six stories big but it was all
rusty run down i was with a group of
friends and one of them was scarlett
johansson and she was going through a
rough time lawsuit never mentioned once
something else was going on here one
point she took the van went out there i
chased after her got in the passenger
and i'm like listen you gotta open up
you gotta tell me what's going on
homeless person comes by starts opening
the passenger door window and she's like
no i don't have any money and i was like
well you're kind of a liar and then she
started she's this homeless woman just
started opening the door and then she
didn't want money she instead gave us a
crucifix and then shut the door but she
had wide eyes then i woke up
hey let's watch this
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
today we have a deleted alternate
post-credits scene that would have been
in black widow if they had decided to go
this route and depending on your views
you could actually think that this would
have been a better post-credit scene for
natasha
they could have thrown this in with the
other post credit scene with mason and
not had to choose between the two of
them they could have done this one first
and the one with mason and the quinjet
after but i'll let you decide for
yourself i'll show some clips and the
stills so it doesn't get copyrighted but
i'll show it nonetheless then of course
after i'll break it down and we'll talk
about what exactly this scene would have
meant if it was kept in the movie okay
so it's about a minute long and we start
off by seeing a motorcycle come down a
street in a neighborhood we then see
some kids run outside of a house and we
see the motorcycle ride even more down
into the neighborhood as we see the kids
in the neighborhood play a little bit
more we can actually see that they're
acting and playing like they're the
avengers we see two little girls run by
one of them seems to have some type of
wings on her back she could be acting
like she's falcon
did you say she's acting like she's
falcon because she's a little black girl
oh she's she's black falcon huh yeah is
that what you're doing yeah she's
pushing is that your award last thing
you need right now is for a white
youtuber to look racist
so what do you think you're doing man
you're canceled warren you're canceled
we successfully did it let's continue
the video the girl behind her has black
bands on her arms acting like she's
natasha then a boy runs by that has the
same black bands on as well acting like
he is natasha we then see a kid with a
bow obviously pretending like he's
hawkeye and we also see a kid jumping on
a trampoline with a small captain
america shield kind of like a one for
toddlers that you would just go to
target and pick up one for idiots all
these kids learn very early on what it's
like to film for a movie and not be
featured in it
that's being a little supporting actor
isn't it
yeah none of our friends believe them
anymore so as these kids are playing
avengers natasha comes around the corner
stops her bike gets off and takes her
helmet off she looks up and the house
that she grew up in as a child for those
few years with her so called family with
yelena bilova molina vasikov and alexis
shostakov aka the red guardian and we
can see that
guarding the house at the house
reminiscing of her past clearly very
emotional some of the kids that were
playing avengers walk by her the kid
with the captain america shield runs
right by her however the little girl who
was playing like she was black widow
recognizes her she walks up slowly
behind her checking to see if it really
is her natasha smiles at her then the
little girl realizing that it's her
holds up her arm with her pretend black
widow bracelet and gives her a little
black widow bite natasha holds up her
arm and pretends to do the same back to
her and that's the scene now keep in
mind this is great
post credit scene this is an alternate
ending which i assume will be released
when the movie actually comes out on dvd
and blu-ray uh i i love that because
there's that little exchange that
florence pew and her have where they're
like i'm not the kind of superhero
little girls look up to and then you see
this scene right here where a little
girl is looking up there
would have been a little bit of great
fantastic movie like my heart was a
little warm
that had so much emotional resonance i
thought that was really sweet
whatever
this would have replaced the scene with
mason where she rides up on her bike and
she gets the quinjet and that scene
really has more connections to infinity
war because we know that after she gets
in the quinjet she goes and breaks some
of her fellow heroes out of the raft so
i can definitely see why they went with
that scene instead of this scene it
connects a lot more to the events that
were about to happen in infinity war
however although in the mcu's timeline
infinity war had not taken place yet in
real life it had and i think a lot of
people realize what natasha would go on
to do she would go on to fight in
infinity war and then avengers in-game
and then ultimately die and since we
ourselves and a good majority of the
people know that i think this alternate
ending is a little bit more emotional
and i think it kind of ties you into
natasha just a little bit more you feel
for her one last time and i think it
really just depends on what you would
want to feel at the end of the movie
would you want to feel a more emotional
connection to natasha a kind of happy
emotional scene right here where we see
that she's inspired little girls and
little boys as a hero and not as a
russian assassin or would you have
wanted what we actually got i would have
wanted a scene that sets you up for a
movie i already saw a couple years ago
that's right man give me what i already
know i want familiarity that's what i
want warren why leave us off on an
emotional beast
for this character who's dead and we're
not gonna see anymore and i actually
think that they probably could have done
both they could have shown this scene
and then shown the other scene with
mason now clearly the movie was super
long and they needed to cut some parts
but i feel like if you don't see it was
way too long and then took a little bit
from the scene with mason and the
quinjet you probably could have put them
both together because think about this
and this is actually why i prefer this
scene over the quinjet scene this would
have been the last time that we saw
black widow the last time ever seen
natasha on screen if you take away all
of the different multiversal aspects of
it the variant aspects of it yes perhaps
we could see a variant of her one day or
maybe not depending on the recent
reports which i'll talk about at the end
but if you put all of that aside this
would be the last time that we actually
get to see natasha in the mcu on screen
and for that sole reason is why i
actually prefer this deleted alternate
ending why because it actually shows
natasha in a very good light because the
black widow movie is all about her this
is her film it's about her tackling her
past it's about her coming face-to-face
with dracob again about her coming
face-to-face with antonia yeah
she's saying all the things that's the
very first avengers film the whole story
is that she was an assassin before she
killed a lot of people but ultimately
she turned good and did what she had to
do to go down the right path and in the
movie they actually kind of talk about
this yolina and natasha natasha says i
was trying to do something good be more
than just a trained killer and yelena
says you're fooling yourself we are
still both trained killers i'm not the
killer that little girls call their hero
this is a draw
on the same
page is clearly stating that she wants
to be more than what she had been she
wants to be a hero and what this scene
does is actually solidify the fact that
she is indeed a hero and she's a hero
not only to us but to the actual people
inside the mcu she made a real impact
little girls and little boys are
pretending to be her because they look
up to her and that's why i personally
really like this scene better than the
one that we got not that i didn't really
like it i just would have preferred this
one well also just in terms of
storytelling elements for a bookend
where you start off where your prologue
with natasha is this traumatized little
girl stripped away from her family not
her real family and then so much of this
movie she's dealing with you're not my
real family i don't really view you guys
as to happen that she's coming to this
scene if we had this scene it would have
been a moment of acceptance of
resolution from the traumatic past and
accepting like no this was my family
life the embrace of where this journey
starting from that flashback prologue to
where she is now that it turned her into
a hero it's just it's so much stronger
yeah it's so much stronger it would be a
literal homecoming and it would be her
accepting what her home actually was
would have been perfect i would have
loved this i would have given it a
higher recommendation what i would have
done whole grade level higher but in the
meantime let me know what you think
about this alternate ending for black
widow would you have preferred this or
do you like the one that we got
be sure to tell me in the comments down
below don't forget to subscribe and hit
that notification bell so you do it all
in the mcu don't forget to like the
video if you enjoyed it and for live
updates you can always follow me on
instagram and twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching
thank you boring
send you a text momentarily guys
subscribe to warren if you haven't done
so already i have it on good authority
he's going to be covering marvel's what
if and so will we but he'll be doing the
breakdowns and all those shenanigans
guys which ending would you have
preferred i personally would have
preferred this one
subscribe to the real rejects to hear
more about greg's dreams click that
notification bell hit that like button
last but not least let's do a
niraj krishnan listen man after the
events of black widow no more women
widows we need black widow men now and
you're the guy for the job if there's
anyone out there who can resist the will
of some evil pheromones it's going to be
you i believe in you have a deviated
septum and that deviated septum might
make it easier to not have the scent
affect yourself man so
you are the next wave of trained
assassins around the world what's more
deadly and we have too much of in this
world
men men men see what i did i gender
swapped it i have made it reverse woke
here because the female the male
niraj she's sick mother effort you go
out there and i hope
you just annihilate all kinds of bad out
there because that's what naraj means
in hindu
naraj
[Music]